tonight is fight night Elizabeth Warren
prepares to take on Joe Biden Democrats
try somewhat unconstitutional methods to
push gun control and president Trump's
asylum policy receives a reprieve from
the Supreme Court this is the Ben
Shapiro show are you pumped brother
because tonight is the real fight night
get ready for Elizabeth Warren Joe Biden
on the same stage two old people going
at each other with the tennis balls on
the bottom of their Walker's it's gonna
be unbelievable you're gonna love every
moment of Elizabeth Warren yelling at
you like she's an annoying member of
your HOA and Joe Biden walking into
things it's gonna be incredible we'll go
through all of the preview for that plus
Democrats are now pushing this new
method of gun control it's called let's
violate the First Amendment repeatedly
by not passing any laws but pressuring
private companies not to do legal things
we'll get into all of that in just one
second first let's talk about the
economic volatility that we've been
seeing so we've been seeing enormous
economic volatility of late a lot of
expectations about where the economy is
gonna go over the next couple of years
has people rushing to what they consider
safe for commodities things like bonds
as well as to gold
well can you afford another head to your
retirement like the last downturn when
the S&P dropped 50% you should be
diversified into some of those safer
assets and you know what one of those
safer assets would be precious metals
you know how I use for precious metals
investment that would be Birch gold
group hedge against inflation hedge
against uncertainty and instability with
precious metals my savings plan is
diversified and yours should be as well
the company I trust with precious metal
purchases his Birch gold group look back
historically when the bottom falls out
of everything else gold does tend to
safeguard savings Birch gold group has
thousands of satisfied customers
countless five-star reviews an A+ rating
with the Better Business Bureau contacts
Birch gold group right now a free
information kit unphysical precious
metals see if diversifying into gold and
silver makes some sense for you this
comprehensive 16 page kit shows how gold
and silver can protect your savings and
how you can legally move that IRA or
401k out of stocks and bonds and into a
precious metals IRA if that's something
you choose to do I'm not saying take all
your money and stuff it into gold and
then bury it in your backyard I'm saying
you should be diversified into precious
metals at least a little bit to protect
yourself to get your no cost no
obligation kit text Ben - 47 47 47 again
text Ben my name
- 47 47 47 all right so tonight
tonight's the debate that we've all been
waiting for with bated breath because
it's Joe Biden and Elizabeth Warren on
the same stage now remember we've had
two other debates and randomly Elizabeth
Warren ended up in the debate with all
of the people who don't matter and Joe
Biden ended up in the other debate right
with Kamala Harris who was attacking him
and he ended up on a debate stage with
Bernie Sanders at one point but
Elizabeth Warren has basically been
shielded from any serious criticism of
her on any of the debate stages so far
well tonight she's the one who enters
with a lot of the momentum so there are
two separate polls that show Elizabeth
Warren gaining ground there's one poll
from The Economist YouGov that shows Joe
Biden with 26% support among registered
voters the same thing show the same poll
shows Elizabeth Warren at 26% so they
are tied at 26% in this Economist you go
polled now that economists YouGov poll
has had Elizabeth Warren pulling a lot
stronger than the other polls have been
in the last several months they've shown
Elizabeth Warren within three to four
points in a solid second place over
Bernie Sanders for a very long time that
that poll is a bit of an outlier but
there's another poll from CNN that seems
to confirm at some of this there's a new
CNN SRS SRS poll and it shows that Joe
Biden continues to lead the Democratic
primaries with 24% but that is down five
points from mid-august so in about a
month he's down five points in that CNN
poll meanwhile Elizabeth Warren is now
edging out Bernie Sanders for second
she's at 18% from 14% Bernie Sanders is
at 17% that's slightly up from 15% last
month so in other words Biden looks to
be bleeding in a lot of these polls
while Elizabeth Warren looks to be
gaining and Bernie Sanders actually
looks to be gaining just a little bit in
the Real Clear Politics poll average
Biden is still up fairly substantial
he's got about a 10 point lead on the
rest of the field he's got about 27% in
the Real Clear Politics poll average
with Sanders at 17 and Warren at 17 as
well there's a reuters/ipsos poll that
came out today which is a little bit
more typical of sort of polling data of
late but it has Biden all the way down
at 22% it has Biden at 22 Sanders at 16
Warren at 11 meaning that Biden isn't
riding in the 30% range he needs to be
riding if he wishes to walk away with
this nomination
now that the hill Harris Poll also has
Biden at about 27% with Sanders at
fifteen and worn at 12 so there's
significant differences in these polls
as to whether Warren is in seconds or
whether Sanders is in seconds but Biden
appears to be receding back to the field
just like his hairline once did before
he fixed that the the fact is that Joe
Biden seems to be on the downturn here
and that is because he sort of Gaffin
along nobody's super enthused about him
everybody sort of assumed that he was
going to waltz to the nomination at
least in the conventional media some of
us suggested that his best day would be
his first day and maintained that for
months at a time now Joe Biden still has
solid support in the black community but
if he starts to lose if the aura of
inevitability is gone he's basically
telling remember when Jeb Bush jumped
into the 2016 race he was leading in the
polls he had an established name he was
popular and then he began receding to
the field quite quickly and then he
didn't win a single primary so you could
see that happening with Joe Biden as
time goes on right here now there's
another problem for Joe Biden and that's
not and that he is not nearly as
moderate as he makes himself out to be
now he could run as a solid moderate in
the Democratic Party but what we have
seen from Joe Biden is Biden vacillating
on his positions now maybe that's cuz he
forgot his positions quite possible I
mean he literally doesn't know which
town he is in half the time but Joe
Biden is not nearly as moderate as he
makes himself out to be McClatchy has a
long article about this today talking
about how Joe Biden's platform is
actually a lot more to the left than
Hillary Clinton's was in 2016
according to McClatchy the 2020
Democratic frontrunner emerging policy
agenda is anything but moderate at least
compared to the party's last
presidential nominee from health care to
climate change to criminal justice Biden
has proposed ideas more ambitious and
liberal than policies supported by
Hillary Clinton in the 2016 campaign now
it's not a shock the entire party has
moved to the left but Biden's supposed
to be the moderate taken as a whole how
Biden's policy platform represents a
significant shift from Clinton's
according to McClatchy on nearly every
major issue Biden has either
exponentially increased the scope of
what Clinton proposed or advocated for
new ideas that most Democrats would have
up until now recently considered fringe
the former VP's embrace of an
unabashedly liberal agenda cuts against
some perceptions of him both from
progressives who criticized Biden as
insufficiently bold and center-left
allies who argue he can appeal to voters
in the middle against in in the middle
in an election
Donald Trump now this is an important
point if it appears that Biden is moving
substantially to the left he loses his
reason for being in this race if he is
too moderate he doesn't excite the base
enough to actually win the primaries so
he's stuck between a rock and a hard
place exactly the same thing that would
allow him to win a general election
kills him in the primaries and if he
moves left during the primaries it
undercuts his case that he would be
super electable in a general election so
he is now trapped between the
progressive woek base of the Democratic
Party and the bulk of Americans who are
looking for some sort of return to
normalcy something that is relatively
inoffensive now Biden's been able to
sort of bridge that gap so far by just
being old I really mean that it actually
cuts in his favor see if Biden wants to
appear the safe pick what could be safer
safer then Grandpa Joe wandering around
bumping into the furniture he's not
threatening in any way he's not gonna
take your savings account he doesn't
even know what a savings account is
anymore he's half senile Joe Biden like
the age thing cuts in his favor in the
general election but in the primary it's
exciting anybody and now he's moving to
the left as McClatchy points out Biden's
current set of policy prescriptions
would likely be considered radical if
they had been proposed in any previous
Democratic presidential primary on
health care Hillary Clinton proposed
offering a public insurance plan for
Americans enrolled in healthcare
exchanges she wanted to add adults older
than 55 by a new medicare but Biden goes
much further he wants to allow all
Americans to buy into a public based
plan a government backed insurance plan
a shift some progressives had said would
represent an enormous change to
Obamacare Clinton proposed spending 60
billion dollars on a clean energy fund
Biden wants to spend 1.7 trillion
dollars in federal money to make the
country emit a net of zero carbon
emissions by 2050 Biden is also pushing
to triple title one funding for schools
that educate low-income students and to
abolish the federal death penalty while
encouraging States to do the same
Clinton wanted to maintain capital
punishment in certain situations Biden
is pushing a twenty billion dollar
initiative that encourages States to
reduce their prison population which of
course cuts directly against his old
policy so where is Joe Biden that
remains the question of the day
but Biden is going to be attacking
Elizabeth Warren on the same grounds and
that will be the interesting part of
tonight's debate is that
Joe Biden and Elizabeth Warren have
shifted substantially in their positions
over time Warren is going to suggest
that Biden is ideologically muddled that
Biden is is not coherent in his ideology
but the fact is that Hillary Clinton
that Elizabeth Warren forgive me
Hillary 2.0 is not particularly non
muddled in her past political positions
as we've talked about on this program
she used to be in favor of school
vouchers
she used to be against taxpayer
subsidized tuition she used to be kind
of lukewarm on taxpayer-funded daycare
now she's in favor of all of those
things and every day she comes out with
a new proposal to spend your money and
raise taxes every single day so which
Elizabeth Warren is the real Elizabeth
Warren that is going to be up for debate
tonight and that apparently is the angle
that Joe Biden is going to take now it
is true that the the Bernie Sanders ask
Elizabeth Warren will do better in
primaries but she is less likely to do
well in a general election of course now
all this stuff that sounds great to
primary voters doesn't sound great to
the vast bulk of Americans so you
yesterday there was a big headline about
Elizabeth Warren and Jim Cramer so Jim
Cramer of course the commentator on CNBC
it has Mad Money and Jim Cramer
suggested that Wall Street executives
are panicked about Elizabeth Warren
which is a narrative that cuts very much
in her favor in a primary but when it
comes to a general election do Americans
really want somebody as president who is
panicking all the CEOs on Wall Street
who are responsible for your 401k like
it sounds great until your 401k takes a
massive stock market dump here's Jim
Cramer talking about Elizabeth Warren
how is it possible that this company
cannot find a CEO I mean are they
worried about Elizabeth Warren attacking
that you shoot there he would be of
course they are and of course that
person is why wouldn't they be
I don't know she becomes president what
do you think's gonna happen to the banks
I don't know it's good happen look I've
got a K when you get off the desk II
talk to executives they're more fearful
of her winning I've never heard anybody
say she's gotta be stopped
okay well the the point that that Kramer
is making here again this is a point
supposedly in Laurens favor oh she's
anti corporate who she's gonna hold the
CEOs to the fire there's a little one
problem you know who runs the companies
that hire everybody you know who's
actually responsible for your market
investments in your retirement fund it
would be exactly the people who are
scared bleep less of Elizabeth Warren
now that's not going to be an attack on
her in the primaries that's an attack on
her in the general election in the
primaries the attack on her is going to
be that she's a hypocrite and there are
legs to this attack because she is a
hypocrite okay Elizabeth Warren used to
be a rational irrational reasonable
liberal now she's gone off the off the
path in dramatic and insane ways and
she's being ripped I think rightfully so
by a lot of folks in the Joe Biden crowd
who are saying you know this this news
sort of I am the truest bluest Elizabeth
Warren is not real Edie Ren's L is the
former governor of Pennsylvania he's in
the Biden camp he has an editorial in
the Washington Post today going after
Elizabeth Warren he here's what he says
he says I like Elizabeth Warren I like
her a lot too bad she's a hypocrite
he says I think Warren has been a great
senator and her work in setting up the
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau was
terrific
okay fact-check Falls the CFPB is the
best protection ordinary Americans have
from financial institutions that prey on
them fact-checked false in fact I like
her so much when she ran for Senate in
2018 i co-chaired a couple of
fundraisers for her and donated a
combined $4,500 to her campaign shortly
after announcing her candidacy for the
Democratic presidential nomination in
February says at Rennes Elle Warren said
she would shun high-dollar fundraising
events that means no fancy receptions or
big-money fundraisers only with people
who can write the big checks Warren
wrote in an email to supporters now
Warren has every right to make that
pledge even if she had obtained
significant contributions from donors in
the past doing that doesn't make her a
hypocrite but there are two other
reasons why the description applies
first because she transferred ten point
four million dollars from her Senate
re-election campaign to her presidential
campaign fund more than six million
dollars came in contributions of a
thousand
and up as the New York Times recently
noted the senator appears to be trying
to have it both ways get the political
upside from issuing donations from
higher level donors and running a
grassroots campaign while at the same
time using money obtained from those
donors in 2018 that ten point four
million dollars gave Morin a substantial
head start in building a presidential
campaign staff and doing other things
for which money is essential if she
wasn't being hypocritical she would have
taken only the dollars raised in smaller
increments from her Senate race and
transferred those into her presidential
account second Warren attacked former VP
Joe Biden for holding a kickoff
fundraiser in Philadelphia in April
which she criticized as quote a swanky
private fundraiser for wealthy donors in
an email to supporters the next day
Wells has had Ren's al I helped organize
that affair and I thought her attack was
extremely hypocritical because nearly 20
of us who attended the Biden fundraiser
had also given her two thousand dollars
or more in 2018 that close to our fund
raisers in swanky locations Warren
didn't seem to have any trouble taking
our money in 2018 but suddenly we were
power brokers and influence peddlers in
2019 the year before we were wonderful i
co-chaired one of the events for the
senator and received a glowing
handwritten thank-you letter from her
from my for my hard work it seemed odd
to some of us who gave her money that
Warren was experiencing an epiphany less
than 12 months later it's one thing to
fashion a campaign that relies on
grassroots fundraising says had Ren's L
but it's another to go out of your way
to characterize as power brokers and
influence peddlers the very people who
support you have previously courted he
says Warren isn't the only person who
had been hypocritical about fund raising
Barack Obama did the same thing he says
he vowed not to take any money from the
political action committees of Wall
Street firms in his 2008 campaign but
his campaign took in millions of dollars
from individuals who worked for Wall
Street firms but the news media
basically gave Obama a free ride and
didn't point out the blatant hypocrisy
of trying to win credit for shunning
contributions from Wall Street firms
while taking tons of money from people
who work for the same Wall Street firms
politics can make people do peculiar
things funny that brands all had nothing
to say about this in 2008 so far as I
recall he says I also take issue with
the notion raised by Warren in her
criticism of the Biden fundraiser in
April that people who give the maximum
allowable individual donation of 2,800
bucks to a presidential candidate are
doing so because they believe it will
get them a federal job when their
business and Federal contract or even
gain special access hey by the way at
Ren's L welcome to the anti campaign
finance reform side of this hour
I'm making this argument for years if
you really believe that rich donors are
given 3,000 bucks to buy special access
to a politician as opposed to because
they want to see the politician win I'm
not sure which donors you're talking to
most of the donors I know who can afford
to give 2,800 bucks don't consider that
to be a massive donation in any way
shape or form Randall says donors who
give 2,800 bucks for the most part are
doing so because they believe strongly
that the candidate would make a great
leader or maybe they believe in the
candidates values or policies on the
important issues challenging the country
he says that are there some people who
give or raise money in presidential
campaigns with ulterior motives
sure but I'm confident the crowd at the
Biden fundraiser gave money to him for
the same reason that I did so despite my
feelings Elizabeth if you're reading
this and you win the Democratic
nomination I'll be happy to support you
will campaign for you with all my heart
and by the way Philadelphia has a lot
more swanky restaurants we haven't seen
yet pretty harsh words from Edie and
this will be the line of attack by Joe
Biden on Elizabeth Warren tonight is
that she is refashioned herself in
Bernie Sanders mole but she has only
done that for the sake of convenience
after running for Senate in 2018 and
then she took that in she is now flipped
to I'm the most progressive senator in
the world by the way all of these are
lines of attack that Donald Trump is
going to use against her and we'll use
to good effect because Donald Trump is a
brawler right Donald Trump is somebody
who will fight you and fight you hard
okay so we'll get to that in just one
second first let's talk about
neighborhood safety so the fact of the
matter is that I am deeply concerned
about safety the reason that I am deeply
concerned about safety is because there
are lots of death threats against me
people have tried to come to my house
people have tried to target my family
I'm really worried about safety and when
I'm not home I want to make sure I know
who is at the front door all the time
well the way to make that happen for me
has been ring rings mission is to make
neighborhoods safer you might already
know about their smart video doorbells
and cameras that protect millions of
people everywhere ring helps you stay
connected to your home anywhere in the
world so if there's a package delivery
or a surprise visitor you'll get an
alert and be able to see hear and speak
to them all from your phone as a
subscriber you have a special offer on a
ring welcome kit available right this
very instant at ring.com slash been
again that's ring comm /ban the kit
includes the ring video doorbell - and a
chime Pro which is just what you need to
start building a ring of security around
your home today go to ring.com slash pen
that is ring.com
slash Ben
again I have ring devices because I want
to keep my home safe I want to know
who's at my front door ringing the
doorbell and then I can pick it up from
anywhere so I know exactly who is there
and whether they are safe or not go to
ring.com slash band that is ring comm
slash Ben and you have a special offer
available on that ring welcome Kent
additional terms may apply again ring
accomplished men people I trust with my
home security you should trust them -
because I care a lot about security and
so should you okay so Bloomberg is
reporting that Joe Biden plans to argue
at this week's debate that all
presidential candidates including the
incumbent must be transparent about
their finances and any business dealings
in their past that of course is directed
Elizabeth Elizabeth Warren why well
because Elizabeth Warren has done a fair
bit of corporate consulting over the
years the lady who likes to rip on CEOs
and corporations now she's gotten paid
by CEOs and corporations to consult with
their firms before the Biden advisors
said voters deserve visibility into
candidates finances especially from
those who are facing questions about
their activities before taking office
the advisors declined to confirm whether
Warren would be Biden's explicit target
with her polling in second place in many
state and national polls the former VP's
team is paying close attention to her
while Warren has posted tax returns
dating back to 2008 on her campaign
website the Biden camp appears to be
calling for greatness greater scrutiny
of the years before 2008 that was the
year that choose appointed to the
congressional oversight panel that
examined government response to the
financial crisis Warren whose
presidential effort is styled around
fighting corporate America has taken on
corporate clients as an advisor or
expert witness on bankruptcy in the last
20 years in May her campaign posted
brief descriptions of her roles in those
cases and some of that work has been
questioned during her - Senate campaigns
in Massachusetts Biden may be an
imperfect messenger for the argument
because obviously Biden has some
corporate concerns of his own people
raising questions about his associations
with his son hunter and business
dealings between hunter and foreign
countries while Biden was vice president
but the real key here is undermining
Warren's image as a candidate of
progressive integrity because all Biden
really has to do is knock Warren down
one peg he doesn't have to knock her out
of the race he has to knock her down one
peg behind Sanders any wins the
nomination right that is his goal and
you know knows this is Bernie Sanders
right Bernie Sanders is very well aware
that his best angle here is to let Biden
and Warren fight it out hope that Biden
knocks Warren down and then he gets
to pick up that progressive vote because
there's one thing that you can say about
Sanders you can't say about Warren and
that is he has been entirely consistent
in his communist takács Enda since day
one since he was mayor of Burlington
Vermont
so Sanders is the real true believer
here and he's been avoiding attacking
Warren because he doesn't want to look
mean he wants to look as the Warren as
an ally that he sort of her ideological
forbear which is really weird because
again Elizabeth Warren as a human I mean
I know Elizabeth Warren a little bit
much smarter than Bernie Sanders just as
a human being much smarter much more
nuanced much more interesting and I
think her deep down views she has
abandoned all of that to run his sort of
Bernie light who is more articulate and
has more plans and that's why every day
she comes out with a new plan and she
has a new plan today to give Social
Security beneficiaries erases Social
Security's already bankrupt
hey Social Security is not paying for
itself it is already running in the red
the government is taking in less money
for Social Security year on year than it
is handing out Elizabeth Warren wants to
spend more money on Social Security
where's that money gonna come from she's
gonna raise your taxes of course she
wants to raise taxes on people who make
more than two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars a year now I'm not sure if
that's household or people that makes a
fairly large difference because if you
have two members of your household one
making one hundred fifty one making one
hundred that does not necessarily mean
that you are just raking in the dough I
mean if you're living in a major city
like Los Angeles or New York that puts
you in like the low end of rich that's
not put you in the in the midst of
wealth okay but regardless Elizabeth
Warren seems to think that people who
are wealthy are the cash cow in the
United States and can be milked and
milked and milked despite the fact that
the United States has taken in about the
same percentage of GDP for government
revenue for the last 60 or 70 years I
mean even in the even in the cases where
the top tax bracket was like ninety-one
percent it applied to very few people
applied to people at the very very very
top and most of those people avoided
those tax brackets because the effective
tax rate ended up being significantly
lower Elizabeth Warren wants to correct
all that and grab an enormous amount of
revenue from people at the top
supposedly assuming that they won't
avoid all of that so once again she's
just making more promises to people that
she can't keep well Bernie Sanders all
he has to do is sort of lay off Warren
and he's basically pledged to do this so
last week he was on the view and he was
asked about Elizabeth Warren and people
have been wondering why isn't Sanders
going
Warren because he knows that Biden's
gonna go up Warren he knows that Biden
has no interest in going after Bernie
Sanders because Biden looks at Bernie
Sanders and realizes that Sanders isn't
direct threat to him Warren is a direct
threat so Sanders is hope tonight is
that he can stand off to the side and
shout at the clouds like like grandpa
Simpson and that Warren and Biden will
go at it and he'll just stand over here
going I'm the true eye
you wanted the coolest I have never
taken money from corporate interests
unlike my good friend a little bit more
right that's what he wants he doesn't
want to have to say Warren's name he
made that pretty clear on the view last
week let's talk about then senator
Elizabeth Warren because not only is she
a friend of yours she shares a lot of
the same ideas that you came out with
first she's saying Medicare for all free
public college the green New Deal is
there enough room in the party for both
of you because are you now in danger of
splitting the vote and giving Joe Biden
a clear path to the nomination well
sorry Elizabeth is a friend when she and
I have known each other for well over 20
years
and she's gonna run hard campaign and I
will run my campaign okay so Sanders is
going to avoid her like the plague the
same way he avoided Hillary Clinton
until it became inevitable he had to
attack Hillary Clinton he's gonna try
the same strategy with with Elizabeth
Warren and hoped that Biden really does
damage to Elizabeth Warren so that's the
dynamic on the stage tonight then you're
gonna have all of the sort of peons on
the stage the beta O'Rourke's who's
gonna be shouting about gun control
endlessly and cory booker who's going to
be desperately seeking attention with
his angry eyes
so mr. Potatohead with his angry eyes
you know of Kamala Harris who will
switch her positions repeatedly on stage
while trying to arrest everybody that'll
be exciting people who'd a judge will
give you a little bit of biblical
exegesis based on the idea that Jesus
was super into abortion so that that
should be exciting but everybody knows
that the main fight right all this stuff
is undercard stuff the main fight
tonight is going to be between Biden and
Warren and Biden does have to take
Warren down a peg because she is picking
up a lot of support and the media love
her because as I have said before when
it comes to support in the media people
tend to support the candidate that makes
them feel better about themselves and
all the people in the media wants to
view themselves as intelligent they
think that Warren is intelligent and
thus they support Elizabeth Warren they
don't want to view themselves as back to
normalcy
non
visionary regular old Joe voters and so
they don't support your Biden in any
real way now in just one second I want
to get to the the attempt by the media
to paint this race as the female race
they have to distinguish Elizabeth
Warren from Bernie Sanders on one hand
and Joe Biden on the other and so
naturally the media are going exactly
where you would think they are going
which is to Elizabeth Warren is a female
and the reason people don't like her is
because she's a whole woman cuz she's a
whole absolute crap we'll get to that in
just one second first let's talk about
looking good in a suit so I know what
you think you think you can just go down
to your local department store and pick
a suit up off the rack and it's gonna
fit you like wrong it's gonna hang off
you like drapes okay what you really
need is a tailored so you want to look
like James Bond well you got a shop like
James Bond that means a personalized
suit and that is where Indo Chino comes
in they make suits and shirts to your
exact measurements your Indo Chino suit
is made for you
they've got attention to detail to beat
any department store if you're in the
middle of planning a wedding they have
tons of options for people looking to
outfit their wedding party so here's how
it works you can visit one of their
showrooms I've done this before it's a
lot of fun Indo Chino has over 40
showrooms in North America and a stylist
will take your measurements personally
or you can measure at home and shop
online at Indo Chino dot-com you choose
your fabric inside now you can choose
lapel lining buttons you can even write
your own monogram Indo Chino will then
professionally tailor your suit and mail
it to you in just a couple of weeks and
a suit that is made for you is going to
fit you like a suit made for you
right everything in life is becoming
more personalized why not the clothing
that you wear this week my listeners can
get any premium Indo Chino suit for just
369 bucks at ENSO chinos calm when
entering promo code Shapiro's at
checkout plus shipping is free
that's Indo Chino com promo code Shapiro
for any premium suit for just 369 bucks
and free shipping it's a fantastic deal
for a premium made-to-measure suit
once you go custom you're not gonna want
to go back go check them out at Indo
Chino calm and use that promo code
Shapiro for these special discounts ok
so the media of course are trying to
paint this race as stop being mean to
the females stop being mean to the women
and this is where we get a wonderful
this is where we get the picture of the
day the best picture of the day because
they tried this with another candidate
in 2016 you'll recall Americans were
sexist if they didn't vote for Hillary
Clinton well Americans did vote for
Hillary Clinton by popular
about but they didn't buy electoral vote
and now Hillary Clinton wanders the
earth sadly looking for relevance this
is just I don't know if this is the
saddest picture I've ever seen or the
happiest picture I've ever seen I'm
having a tough time deciding so if you
get this why should subscribe folks at
daily wire because then you can actually
see this picture is a picture of Hillary
Clinton at some sort of book signing
sitting behind a fake resolute desk said
because she's not behind the real
resolute desk because she wasn't not
elected president she's sitting behind
the fake resolute desk grinning with a
bunch of papers in front of her Hillary
Clinton has literally become Miss
Havisham from Charles Dickens remember
Miss Havisham who the the old spinster
who was once engaged then jilted at the
altar and now she's sixty and she runs
around hurt her decaying mansion wearing
her wedding dress from forty years
beforehand that is Hillary Clinton hell
it looked me Clinton is like you know
what I'm gonna I don't know how you guys
I need to get behind this desk and
pretend just for a little while that I'm
that I'm President of the United States
I need to pretend I'm gonna get behind
this resolute desk and I'm pretend just
for a little while that my best memory
of this resolute desk is not Monica
Lewinsky beneath it but actually just me
sitting behind it as though I were
President of the United States I mean
wow that is that is a sad human being
that is a very sad him like some people
lose an Electra and they go on to have a
life like Mitt Romney and he lost an
election and then he went on and he had
a life he got elected she said it and he
was doing some charity work
Al Gore lost an election won the popular
vote lost the election went and spent
the next several next couple of decades
finding about the effects of climate
change and making billions of dollars
off of it and leading himself a life
right winning an Oscar and John Kerry
went on to be Secretary of State Hillary
Clinton loses an election and she is
basically Stacey Abrams in this thing
right she actually she's gonna just
claim that she won and she's gonna I
mean that is that I have to say I love
this picture I almost want to have it
framed it framed and signed by Donald
Trump I think I can make that happen for
myself really like it this this now
occurs to me that I know enough people
close to President Trump that I feel
like I could probably get this picture
signed by President Trump and it would
be the ultimate in wall
Hilary Clinton sitting behind the fake
resolute desk never having accepted that
she lost the election in any case you
recall back to the 2016 election when
America was informed that you were
sexist if you don't vote for Hillary
Clinton well now we're gonna do the same
thing but with Elizabeth Warren Veronica
Roo Curt has a piece
she is a Peabody award-winning former
public radio host a voice coach and
communications expert she has a piece
today in the Washington Post titled that
grating noise it's people criticizing
female voices on the debate stage she
says as the TEL at the televised
Democratic presidential debate primary
on Thursday three voices will issue from
the Houston stage to convince voters
that the next president of the United
States can do something no one in the
history of the office has ever done
sound like woman Wow Bill Clinton
sometimes sounded like a woman but in
any case she says if this doesn't seem
revolutionary it should remember the
continuous spray of adjectives metaphors
and pundits reapplied to the subject of
Hillary Clinton's voice Glenn Beck
likened it to an ice pick in the ear
when is technically correct
shrill was another popular choice along
with the implication imagine listening
to that for four years I believe I
actually said that exact phrase imagine
listening to that for 40 meanwhile the
voices of senator Bernie Sanders and
Donald Trump battered and nasal skated
past no notice now I'm pretty sure that
I make fun of Bernie Sanders on a
regular basis that Bernie Sanders
talking about which is funny Brooklyn
accent and it sounds like he swallowed
some sort of hippopotamus like that's
I'm it flew his voice all the time but I
do love that we now have to paint this
picture of Elizabeth Warren his victim
you don't understand the glowing media
coverage she has received heretofore the
glowing media Washington Post theater
critic wrote an entire piece we went
through it an entire piece about how she
was like Shakespearean level actor how
she drew you to beyond yourself uh oh I
mean the guy basically did a meg Ryan in
When Harry Met Sally
and he basically orgasms while he was
writing the piece he brought himself all
the way and and yet we're supposed to
believe that Elizabeth Warren is
victimized by people pointing out that
actually her voice is a little bit
wobbly and that she and that she goes
down into this register a lot which is
something I hate in all politicians
including politicians I like I always
used to make fun of Ted Cruz's sincere
boy
when Ted would get real sincere you'd go
down here and that's when you knew he
was being sincere and I hate when
politicians of any stripe do that but
according to Veronica Ruger and it's all
about the fact that Elizabeth Warren is
a woman she's a woman and that is why we
have to be nice to her and not make fun
of her voice as opposed to everybody
else Veronica root says women have been
given a famously narrow road to walk
step to one side and they are strident
hysterical and grading step to the other
and they are uninvested passionless
robots well know sometimes women are
strident hysterical and grating and
sometimes they're uninvested passionless
robots and sometimes they're actually
fine right sometimes nikki Haley is
great sometimes sometimes on the
Democratic side I don't find Amy klava
car to be grating maybe we judge each
individual pretty harshly because
they're in politics you know me people
make fun of my voice and my cadence
there are literal TV episodes dedicated
to my voice and cadence so like get over
it gang I don't think they're making fun
of me because I'm a Jewish man I think
they're making fun of me because I have
a funny voice and a funny cadence like
whatever deal with it but this is the
new narrative is that if anyone attacks
Elizabeth Warren's cadence or her
performance it's because you hate women
it's cuz of that yeah good luck with
that agenda if that's the best Elizabeth
Warren can do when Donald Trump comes
for her on the basis of the fact that
she is a habitual liar in both her
policy and with regard to her her own
past as a Native American princess
wandering the prairies if the best they
can do is he's a sexist then they better
prepare a fake resolute desk for her -
okay I'm gonna go great in just a second
we're gonna get to the Democratic agenda
now all of them here's the thing the
entire debate right now is based on not
Donald Trump right that's that's really
the Democratic pitches not Donald Trump
and that's a fairly solid pitch and then
they start coming forth with their
policies and you can see it on the state
level and it is ugly and it is in many
cases unconstitutional and it's a real
problem we'll get to some of these bad
policies in democratic states which will
filter up to the feds in just one second
first you have to go over to Daley wire
calm and subscribe if you want to see
the rest of the show live or if you want
to see the show at all right I mean if
you want to get it commercial free if
you want two additional hours of me and
the afternoon with you three hours of
show just for you we
have access to the backstages we have
access to the mailbag all sorts of
goodies you have to be subscribed over
its daily wire and for $99 here you get
this the very greatest in beverage
vessels I mean this thing is life-giving
how life-giving is the leftist years how
turn cold tumbler I'll tell you how
life-giving the leftist year's hot or
cold tumbler is we left it in here
overnight one time and I came back the
next morning and there was a fly
swimming around in the leftist here
hotter it had not died it had remained
alive inside here now any normal fly
would have died but I promise you this
thing is just I don't promise because
that'd be false advertising but I can
only say from anecdotal evidence the
creatures that have fallen into the
leftist tiers tumbler it's been sort of
like the regeneration pit from Batman it
basically it may grant eternal life I
don't know I don't know we haven't no
one I know is died while drinking from
it we'll put it that way in any case go
check us how to daily we're calm you get
the annual subscription for $99 a year
also you're helping us out you're
protecting us from the left that wishes
TD platform everybody you become part of
the team please check us out we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
all right so let's get to some of the
Democratic policies on the federal and
state level that Americans are going to
run screaming from on a broad level now
they may not understand the consequences
of these things yet but they should they
should okay so let's talk about one
policy that was undertaken by governor
Phillip Murphy Democrat of New Jersey
yesterday according to Nick chorus and
Edie over at the New York Times New
Jersey will stop doing business with gun
manufacturers and retailers that failed
to adopt policies that go beyond federal
laws like conducting expanded background
checks to stop guns from falling into
the wrong hands
becoming the first state to take such
stringent action against the firearms
industry so you should understand what
this means it is not illegal for any of
these companies to do what they are
doing there is no violation of federal
law
there's no accusation of discrimination
there's no accusation that would make
state cooperation with these entities or
contracting with these entities Violet
of a federal law right there are federal
statutes for example that prevent the
federal government from contracting with
discriminatory companies on the basis of
race hey there's nothing like that with
regard to here's a company that sells
guns because that's not illegal nor
should it be illegal in fact the Second
Amendment protects precisely that sort
of thing yet the state of New Jersey is
now saying they will not contract with a
company like Walmart
unless Walmart does what New Jersey
wants to do but cannot even legislate on
guns so they're not saying you have to
comply with New Jersey law they're
saying you have to go beyond New Jersey
law and if you don't go beyond New
Jersey law we're not gonna contract with
you now this seems to me a First
Amendment violation there's something
called viewpoint discrimination the
federal and state governments that are
not allowed to discriminate against any
contractor or any person on the basis
simply a viewpoint and I disagree with
you I'm not discriminating in violation
of anti-discrimination law or anything I
just disagree with you about gun control
and the state says you know I can't
contract with that guy because he
disagrees with me about gun control
because he's a gun seller so I'm not
doing business with him I've done
nothing illegal you have no excuse to
discriminate against my business and yet
that's exactly what New Jersey is
seeking to do because the left has
discovered that it is far easier to
pressure companies into doing their
bidding with the government threatening
them and with the government using the
power of the gun to kind of subtly say
well you know be a shame if something
happened to your
they're sure we can't let just let you
out of existence but we can certainly
make your business a little tougher
can't we so we're just gonna sit over
here and we're going to play with our
own gun not aiming at it at you per se
we're just gonna waving it around the
room if it happens to stop on you that's
something that might happen but you know
if you comply with us then I'll just put
this thing right back in my pocket and
then we can be friends again the left
has found that it is much easier to
pressure corporate and America into
doing their bidding than it is to get
people to vote for their policies
because the American system of checks
and balances requires tremendous
consensus on a particular issue before
legislation gets done and this is true
even at the state level for the most
part even in blue states like New Jersey
so instead governor's executive branches
in the federal and the state governments
they are now attempting to usurp power
by effectively pushing businesses to go
beyond the letter of the law in ways
that the Governor of New Jersey likes
and you're seeing this from the woke
blue checkmarks on Twitter as well
pressuring Walmart right there was not a
grand upswell of anti Walmart activity
among the consuming public the media
decided they're gonna make it an issue
and Walmart felt okay do we really want
to receive a billion dollars of damaging
press at the hands of a nasty media or
do we just ban the ammo
I guess we'll ban the ammo now the truth
is what corporations should do is they
should all collectively tell all of
these actors blue checkmarks Governor
Phil Murphy to shove it that's what they
should do but they won't why well
because you have a serious collective
action problem which is much easier to
work hand in glove with the government
than it is to stand up to the government
you saw the same things same things sort
of happened in the 1930s with regard to
the car companies a bunch of the car
companies became very dependent on the
FDR administration Henry Ford refused to
go along with that and Ford was
significantly damaged by the FDR
administration in effect it's funny
there's a lot of talk about crony
capitalism this right here is a form of
crony capitalism it is a governor of a
state explicitly benefiting certain
types of companies that back his agenda
politically without the force of law
behind him but with the threat looming
in the wings that he's going to do
something to lead a crusade against a
private business the same people who
were ripping on Donald Trump for going
after companies and I said rightly so
because Donald Trump should not be going
after private companies are doing the
exact same thing so long as those
companies don't agree with them on gun
control
here's governor Phil Murphy doing this
ridiculous and I believe
unconstitutional routine
a couple of days ago I signed an
executive order which essentially puts
our money where our mouth is it has
three parts number one if you're a
vendor and you're selling guns or
ammunition or related equipment to New
Jersey you've got to abide by a set of
principles as it relates to gun safety
secondly if you're a financial
institution and you are lending or
investing in those vendors manufacturers
retailers you also will have to abide by
a set of principles as it relates to gun
safety and thirdly we're gonna review
and ultimately I think banned certain
types of insurance that leads to
irresponsible gun behavior so they're
good they're going to ban insurance you
can't insure yourself against losses
from gun from guns going off or
something liability insurance I mean
this is full-scale insanity this is this
is soft tyranny in action he doesn't
even have legislative approval for this
in New Jersey because you couldn't get
this through the legislature he's just
doing it from the from the executive
branch and again none of these none of
these companies are violating the law
the second step of what he is talking
about is particularly dangerous right
he's saying we won't do business with a
vendor that doesn't abide by a set of
principles that is not established by
law is just what I want them to do a
viewpoint discrimination overtly on its
face hey then you get to the second
thing he is saying which is that if a
bank does business with those businesses
then we won't do business with them and
this is the next step for the for the
radical left what they would like to do
is make it so that you cannot use your
credit card to purchase things the left
doesn't want you to purchase right now
it's guns soon it will be a subscription
to The Daily wire and soon it will be a
subscription to anything that they don't
like right you partake you're giving
money to your church and your church
discriminates against same-sex couples
by only performing traditional marriages
well sorry you can't use visa for that
or MasterCard or American Express that
is where this is going now as I said
with regard to the original Walmart
action on all of this this will
inevitably lead to the rise of other
forms of credit right I mean they're all
start a credit card it'll be the Shapiro
credit card will go out and will find
people who are startup investors to back
that and then you will just use our
credit card for the conservative causes
that you want to use it for so there is
a way out which is why this is not quite
government compulsion but when you have
the Governor of New Jersey pushing it it
starts to look a lot more like
government compulsion and
financial institutions for participating
in fully legal activity the state doing
that is a form of viewpoint
discrimination and it's disgusting and I
hope that everyone sues I hope this
thing ends up in court because it is
absurd it's absurd furthermore you can
see the game so all the same people who
whine about CEOs and corporations and
crony capitalism the Elizabeth Warren
crowd all CEOs are evil they're bad
they've got a Scrooge McDuck money bin
back there and they swim around in their
gold and then they screw their workers
those evil evil CEOs well they also we
need their help to pass gun control so
we are going to simply threaten them and
then we're gonna give them additional
pat you on the head points if they do
what we want according to Amelia Lucas
over at CNBC leaders of 145 companies
wrote a letter to the Senate on Thursday
urging the governmental bodies to take
action on gun safety now let me just
point out if 145 companies wrote a
letter to the Senate cutting against
financial regulation by Elizabeth Warren
and her fellow senators the media would
be talking about how evil these CEOs are
the media would be talking about how
dare they throw their corporate power
around like this you think their workers
are in favor of this you think their
workers back this and their customers
but you got a hundred and forty-five
CEOs to send a letter talking about why
forever21 wants gun control and suddenly
it's all wow look at them Social
Warriors right there and by the way a
lot of these companies are like forever
I don't think forever 21 is on the list
but it's like uber levi-strauss gap like
who cares what the gap has to say about
gun control you buy a gun at the gap
does the gap make holsters I am unaware
of of course not these are just
companies that are attempting to get in
the good graces of the left by
establishing their own capital account
with well remember that time guys when
we backed gun control and we were all
best buddies remember that well if you
could just see your way clear to like
not looking at foreign labor laws that'd
be awesome
that'd be great like this is it's so
wildly hypocritical and ridiculous in
every possible way but it is an easier
way than actually passing public policy
right you can't pass a bill so you just
push corporations to do this stuff for
you because they're risk-averse and
they're looking for an anodyne corporate
culture where everybody agrees when
there was talk in the 1950s and Marxists
used to criticize the so called
corporate man at the idea
corporations were interested in churning
out basically widget human beings human
beings that all look the same the man in
the gray flannel suit and it was
exaggerated because it turned out that a
lot of people were still individuals
they just wore similar suits to the
office well now corporations more than
ever because of social pressure are
trying to turn out good little liberals
who abide by all of the various policy
preferences of big city Democrats
because they don't want the risk because
they don't want the risk
well eventually the right is going to
wake up to this and the risk is going to
be countered because every time a
corporation does this sort of thing
there will be blowback from the right
and competitors from the right who start
up and take a portion of the business if
you politicize everything the right will
have to politicize back now that's not
the world that I prefer the world that I
prefer is a world where gap can sell
whatever it wants so long as it's legal
and Dick's Sporting Goods and Walmart
can sell whatever they want so long as
they're legal and you don't have Rahm
Emanuel threatening to ban chick-fil-a
just because he doesn't like the CEO all
that stuff is is gross and ugly but
that's not the world that the left is
allowed or created and so things are
gonna get a lot worse before they get
better now speaking of bad democratic
policy yesterday the the Democrats were
pushing again on immigration
AOC the illustrious brilliant AOC she
was talking about deporting migrants
with disabilities so the idea I guess is
that if you have a disability and you
come into the country and you falsely
claim asylum we can't deport you anymore
she says this is a form of killing them
she's a delight AOC folks and people
like mr. Sanchez and Miss puesto are not
collateral damage to this
administration's policy they are the
target correct correct is targeting or
is targeting and changing policy to
specifically target people with
life-threatening diseases for
deportation essentially killing them
through deportation would you
characterize that as cruel killing them
through deportation so in other words if
you show up on America's doorstep not
claiming asylum but because you want us
to pay your medical bills and we say
well we can't take in everybody in a
minute in the world who has a bad
disease and so we are not going to allow
asylum simply based on we have better
medical care here is that killing people
according to AOC yes of course this is
the same AOC who
attempting to to destroy ice and suggest
that ice is a horrible horrible thing in
fact aoc apologized to migrants on
behalf of the United States there's
nothing more galling than when people
apologize on behalf of other people it's
really irritating LC doesn't get to
apologize on my behalf because I'm not
apologizing on her behalf I don't
apologize to the world on behalf of her
stupidity she doesn't represent me her
views don't represent me but here is AOC
apologizing on behalf of the Trump
administration's dehumanizing policies
apologizing to the world and migrants at
large I'd also like to apologize to you
both for the behavior of some of the
members of this committee where they are
speaking in profoundly dehumanizing
terms to you and you don't deserve that
I like to apologize to you on behalf of
the United States of America for the
dehumanizing policies that they are
pursuing okay so again it said this if
this is the Democratic platform good
luck with this good luck with this
Thomas Holman who is the head of ice he
went after AOC pretty hard he basically
just the way that Ted Cruz owns Deadspin
Thomas Holman apparently owns a us he
just repeatedly he owns her so here he
was yesterday going after a IOC saying
listen if you want to regulate regulate
but if you want to sit here and
about ice doing its job then that is not
actually accomplishing anything ice last
year took of seasonal opioids off the
streets of this country that could have
killed every man woman and child in the
United States twice they've arrested
thousands of sexual predators that the
predator preyed on children they rescued
thousands of children or victims of
predators they arrested hundreds of
women there were victims of sex
trafficking I am proud of the agency and
ice in my 34 years I've never seen such
hate toward law enforcement agency in my
life that you want to sleep okay home
and of course is exactly correct an AOC
can't legislate because even her own
party doesn't back her radical agenda
the Democratic Party would not apologize
because then you just have to establish
another enforcement agency called mice
right I mean would just be something
that would be exactly the same thing but
with a different name it's a democratic
policy again the Democratic primaries
matter but once we get to the general
election if Democrats insist I'm pushing
radical policies things are gonna get
really ugly
and these radical policy
across the board across the country
there's a California bill that is now
going to basically put uber or lyft out
of business why because they're going to
force these companies to treat
independent contractors who work for
uber and lyft as employees how do you
think that's gonna work you think that
uber and lyft are just gonna continue
business as normal that now that they
have to pay for the health insurance of
all of their drivers do you think
they're going to employ people the same
way do you think maybe there'll have to
be a new screening process do you think
that maybe prices will rise on consumers
costing them more money out of their
pockets the answer to all of those
questions is yes but California doesn't
care because California can just throw
them out on the streets where they can
be homeless and then we can pretend that
they have a right to live out on the
streets like California does California
by the way also in an attempt to curb
the homeless problem they've now
approved statewide rent control which of
course is going to result in more
homelessness because rent control is the
stupidest economic policy ever devised
by man rent control is the idea that if
I force you to rent at a lower price you
will continue to build new homes and new
apartment buildings just for the fun of
it without earning the same profit you
would have been able to when you could
up charge people what they were willing
to spend you're gonna end up with less
housing because of your dumb rent
control policies look in New York or
when rent control is really too tight
people are burning down their own
apartment buildings for the insurance
money because it was so unprofitable to
run apartment buildings so yeah it turns
out Democratic policy is a giant fail
and that is what Trump is gonna have to
run on if Trump can avoid his own
foibles already time for a quick thing I
like and then a quick thing that I hate
and we will be out of here so things
that I like I don't know if you've ever
seen bill burrs routine bill burr is
extraordinarily funny he has a new
routine called paper tiger on Netflix
and it is astonishing okay whatever you
thought of Dave Chappelle waking up to
the woke left paper tiger is about as
politically incorrect as any comedy
special I have ever seen
he opens by going after Michelle Obama
which a parent which is we can't do that
I mean she's actually been sainted she's
in line to be canonized by the Pope so
he starts with that and then it goes
downhill from there or uphill depending
on if this is your sort of thing here's
Bill burrs paper tiger a little bit I'm
a married man with the kid but I'll tell
you this right now I've learned anything
in five years of the
married is we're always working on me I
just think to myself like what could my
wife's complaint about my crush
everything I picked up after myself I
like to think I'm a good dad I worked my
ass off make a great living crush all of
that all she has on me is Who I am as a
person
my daughter's yet to meet the real me
she seems okay so that this this
particular preview does not give you the
full spectrum of what the bill burr
special is so it focuses on all the
stuff that's a political yeah it gets
kind of political and frankly I can't
believe this guys still working and I
don't think that the the woke schools
will let him work for very much longer
because all fun things all criticism of
the left must be silenced paper tagger
bill burr go check it out it's pretty
astonishing okay time for a quick thing
that I hate so I have this thing about
people staying in their lanes if you're
an expert on something stay in that lane
right you're a climate change expert
over at MIT stay in that lane if you're
a horror novelist maybe should stay in
that Lane and not try to play political
pundit Stephen King who used to be an
excellent horror novelist you read his
early stuff his early stuff is much
better than his later stuff his later
stuff is basically great premise 800
pages of fussing around everything
explodes as pretty that really that's
like literally every one of his books
for the last 15 years he doesn't know
how to end it this is my criticism of a
lot of Alfred Hitchcock movies as well
great premise develops okay ending is
terrible well in this particular case
that this happens to be true of Stephen
King who hasn't written a truly great
book for probably 15 or 20 years again
I've read a lot of Stephen King I really
enjoy a lot of his work but that model
that I talked about is basically it
right he ends the under the dome the
same way he ends the stand the same way
that he ends most of his other books
great premise really fascinating
everybody blows up at the end the end
maybe a couple people survive in any
case Stephen King went on the view now
again I'm just gonna put this out there
I have never lobbied I'm not gonna sit
here and Lobby to be on the view but you
should put me on the view okay so I've
wanted to be
the view for years I had very few life
aspirations that I have left to that
I've left to really accomplish right I
have a beautiful family I have a nice
house I get to do what I want for a
living rail all sorts of great things
having me there's one thing on that on
that bucket list that I would really
like to check off before I go and that
is being on the view now I don't think
this will ever happen because I think it
would I think the folks of you know why
this would never happen I think this is
an unspoken assumption between me and
the producers of the view why this is a
thing that is never going to happen that
said Stephen King was on the view and of
course we had to solicit his political
opinions because if there's someone
whose political opinions you want it's
somebody who wrote graphic child gang
sex scenes in it that's I desperately
need his opinions on migration go for it
Stephen King I try to keep my politics
separate from the stuff that I write the
stories because I think people like
story
people want story and you know if they
want the news they want to you know the
stuff they can go on and get on MSNBC or
they can long talks or whatever but
sometimes life comes along and imitates
argh a steady the other way around and
as I was rewriting this book all at once
I'd find out what locking little kids up
in cages on the border and I'm thinking
to myself this is like my book okay nope
nope so I love that Stephen King really
believes his books are a political under
the dome is is basically all of his
books have basically just turned into a
riff on Footloose
there's the small-minded sheriff who's
secretly a sexual abuser but is going to
church every day and he's a religious
hypocrite he it's also wrote and it's
also boring and I'm sorry having Stephen
King talk about politics is like having
me write a horror novel right not in my
lane I can criticize it as a reader but
even there you know that's not my area
of expertise I'd rather have Andrew
Clavin steak on it he's an actual
novelist Stephen King on politics it's
like a three-year-old finger painting
you know we can pretend that it's good
and like pretend that it's relevant and
put it on the fridge but it ain't good
it ain't good all righty we'll be back
here later today for two additional
hours of content Plus tonight the big
knock-down drag-out Democratic fight
between the oxygen
and the septuagenarians very very
exciting all the baby boomers go at it
tonight we'll be here tomorrow to cover
all of that I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo white house key
edited by Adam Tsai events audio is
mixed by Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup
is by Jessica alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
if you want to delve the depths of
leftist madness head on over to the
Michael Noel's show where we examine
what's really going on beneath the
surface of our politics and bask in the
simple joys of being right
[Music]